you look so beautiful  then daya shuts down the spider-man  homecoming la première in a seriously  knockout gown your dress now whose  advise this is Russell Russell the  jaw-dropping look turned heads all night  the day of co-star Michael Keaton even  helped out on the red carpet and held  her train up hey crazy it was it was so  much fun and when it comes to clothes  zendaya is always generous did you lend  Tom your leather jacket so y'all are  swapping clothes man because sadly were  the same size like we still has it  somewhere in fact thank you for  reminding me cuz I need to let them know  they need to get that sent back for you  are we going what are you hiding Peter  I'm just getting hungry bye  you